c'est l'humidité qui nous envahit dans
notre repas commun et on n'arrive même
pas à dormir surtout quand il ya là plus
ce père de famille vit dans cet
appartement avec sa femme et ses enfants
depuis un an un logement insalubre
plusieurs dégradations et de l'humidité
une situation difficile accentuée par la
maladie de sa fille atteinte d'un cancer
nous ne pouvons pas laisser une
situation comme celle-là leur avec
othman nasro autour de valérie pécresse
au sein de la région nous allons agir
nous allons mettre la pression
grâce à l'association de locataires pour
dire que nous ne pouvons plus financer
des bailleurs avec des subventions
publiques
s'ils ne font pas leur travail minimum
évidemment l'agglomération je crois à
l'intention de continuer elle aussi a
joué son rôle qui est de faire pression
sur un bailleur pour qu'il respecte ses
obligations légales et c'est triste
qu'on les besoins aujourd'hui on a bien
de visiter une famille qui attend depuis
un an les travaux d'entretien ce cas
n'est pas isolé selon l'association de
défense des locataires 4200 logements
seraient touchés par l'insalubrité
attrape une situation présentée aux élus
du territoire dans les bureaux de
l'association
on a des problèmes aux tirs et 2 de
chauffage d'hygiène de sécurité aussi
mais pas à pas pâton pas de vos points
de vue des locataires c'est à dire que
c'est vraiment les obligations du du
bailleur qui sont pas effectués du côté
du bailleur social valophis n'a pas
donné suite à notre demande d'interview
la société affirme que le dossier est en
cours de traitement